here in Ghana death is celebrated
funerals are a huge deal
Saturday is actually funeral day another
big deal here in Ghana is having a
fantasy coffin you can have a coffin in
the shape of anything that was
meaningful to you in your lifetime
they're considered artworks the best
fantasy coffin maker is Todd Joe Hodge
Olmedo say thank you yes thank you this
is very very nice of you that to share
your artwork with us this is a fish this
fish meant a lot to the person who wants
this fun yes yes maybe this person had a
diet that was low in cholesterol and and
they wanted this coffin is there anyone
in here right now oh good no no good I
don't think a fish would be right for me
I love cheese popcorn maybe a box of
cheese popcorn okay did I lose you on
that one
do people ever get a coffin made in the
shape of the thing that killed them yes
this is a bottle of coca-cola No
so this is someone who died of type 2
diabetes
they will not be sponsoring me anytime
soon your move coca-cola the great thing
about this turkey coffin is that you get
to be the stuffing
are you laughing if you like the Joker
just a good light a light it's not the
cost that carries you off its the coffin
they carry you often this is beautiful
this one yeah the person we die alone
I'm not making you so you keep their
dead butter in the fridge no oh the
person died a long time and the person
you put the body in a refrigerator yes
the family in the meantime has the
person in a refrigerator yes
so in the night they get up to go get
some ice cream they're like dad what is
this this is a chicken
it's a [ __ ] what oh this is rock yeah
it's a cop yeah
so this is someone who had a good time
in life when it's time for me to shuffle
off this mortal coil just shove me in a
cop
my time has come it's the [ __ ] for me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah I love this one I'm gonna want many
of these I can't get enough car I'm
guessing this is the coffin of a Geico
salesman oh ha Joe this is a you just
phoned it in neutral what are thooose oh
that's for the cheese oh this is for
Norman this is just a normal yeah yeah
me and you what's that like you and me
wait time machine thank you whoa in my
own country I'm a great man I'm a great
chief okay
do I seem like a chief to you know this
is a doctor Oh a crab this is a wrap so
this is someone who died of venereal
disease well fitting that it's next to
the cop
I just noticed Pazos calendar vote for
Jesus if Trump were running against
Jesus he would start saying all kinds of
[ __ ] about Jesus you just go after them
he'd have a mean nickname you know what
I like I like messiahs that don't get
caught by the Romans
this is very surreal we asked you to
make me a coffin yeah and to it should
be a coffin of something that means the
most to me let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you captured my face perfectly that's
the face I have when I look at my own
show a sadness that it never quite was
what I wanted to see you know my body
proportions are almost exactly correct
because good insight yes a TV
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]